Forrest Gump was one of many career
defining performances for Tom Hanks it
earned him his second consecutive
Academy Award for best actor along with
endless jokes about his box of
chocolates Mantra and his undying love
for his peas and carrots pal Jenny my
mom always said
life was like a box of chocolates
you never know what you're going to get
although forest's story comes to a
natural conclusion by the film's end
there is actually Source material for a
sequel Winston groom's follow-up novel
Gump and Company which was released a
year after the film premiered and
follows forest's life through the 1980s
Hanks held out on reprising the role
despite reported attempts by the studio
to get Gump pardon the pun up and
running again back in 2022 Hanks told
variety I've always said if there's a
reason to do it let's do it but you guys
can't force me sounds like Hanks is
perfectly content leaving Forest back in
the 90s or rather the 80s